[Music]
[Music]
having been a was there very many times
I've had a great chance to see life
changing the pattern of the lifestyle is
changing very greatly but the
environment itself changing tremendously
the year that I entered however the
subway was completed and open from
Boston to Cambridge and of this time
being really very much evident MIT Viet
could get over to Boston quite rapidly
with MIT must have been been in Boston
in those days and I just because when I
was young I felt the the great change
was taking place that had not been
experienced by my father my grandfather
all the family records I have I thought
it might be a good idea to keep some
record of a other little individual
going in the Victorian period and who's
coming over in some kind of new world
and so I have kept just those records
and I have really very large archives
and they're down to Philadelphia right
now but by which of having them I'm able
to look at records they're changing
things and get sense of rates of change
and have some sense of what may be
unfolding for Humanity on our planet
I think it's very born I was I was seven
when the first automobile came into
Boston I was eight when the Wright
brothers first flew I was brought up as
inherently impossible a man to fly those
are very impressionistic years up to
eight years of age and wow that's how
crazy can you get even though Marconi
had invented the wireless the year that
I was born we don't have an SOS and I'm
12 years of age and so that these are
extraordinary things
becoming many things that I've been told
would never happen were beginning to
happen I was told man would never get to
the North Pole never gets a South Pole
when I was 14 did get the North Pole I
was 16 got the South Pole so there's
there's something that's happening here
that all the world are not expected
that's all that's all I'm trying to get
out of so I felt really very territorial
assessee to keep some kind of record of
the transition I'm sure it's only
because it did start doing that years
ago that you've invited me to be here
tonight because I've been able to able
to keep some track and have some been
able to make some pronounced occasions
that have come true but I don't think
has any ever been a moment our humans on
our planet by humans have really come to
know so much about our planet and about
the local universe where humans have
ever been in such perilous we really are
today I think absolutely on the brink of
our doing way with ourselves and all of
this then relates to I wonder if it'd be
possible like me to have a chair brought
out I serve aspirated in advance
I have podía phobia I don't don't get
behind these things I can't see
[Music]
I think I'll think better if I'm sitting
down cuz I operate entirely I go
thinking out loud
thank you very much as he at the age of
32 in 1927 was the year that Lindbergh
flew across Atlantic which would send a
great change again the human beings not
only was now flying but they were able
to cross great oceans at the age of 32
then I decided to really make an
experiment to the rest of my life trying
to find out what of anything a little
penniless unknown individual might be
able to do effectively on behalf of all
humanity the great nations and great
corporations inherently could not do so
I was just fairly simply to think about
this
luckily I'd been in the night regular
Mountain States Navy and I'd have some
commands and so I could think about the
fact that three crew authors is water
and the Navy was concerned with that
across the world its water out of the
one quality that is dry land about half
it's covered with ice rocks deserts so
the only about one-eighth to the surface
of Earth was propitious for life support
and that at 1/8 is divided up into was
well over 100 nations at the time I was
excited to do my experiment so 100
nations dividing up one Nathan
each one of them tending to look out for
its own it was so much pioneering of
humanity guns it so far you can
generally found yourself being attacked
by others people in America had a little
more luck because they were further away
from the others and read quite clearly
those nations were thinking about
they're fraction of the one-eighth of
the surface of the earth and the great
corporations were operating under the
protection of the various nations and
they they had to make profits with very
short period of time where they go out
of business these bets the way they
thought so they were inherently
short-sighted I saw there was nothing
and nobody was thinking about a total
planet as a ship a spaceship and that
incredibly designed and unbought of it
all these humans and by this time radio
accumulated knowledge great
identification of resources so I said
there's nothing to stop me as a little
individual thinking about then this
total spaceship earth I gave you that
name after a while it became popular and
nothing to stop me then a singing how
how to employ the total knowledge and
the total resources to take care of all
humanity paying absolutely no attention
to any kind of divisions of the humans
being to try and look at it as all
humans and wondering what it what why
but universe to have humans on board in
the universe and have them on board this
little particular planet I felt that the
more I studied the human beings in
contradiction to other organisms ago I
was convinced we have some very
important function to fulfill here in
universe and the universe had no super
gaga's that everything was in universe
is essential to the integrity of the
regeneration of universe so the function
are coming at it very rapidly
differentiating between humans and other
organisms I said all the other living
organisms have some built-in integral
equipment and their owners themselves it
gives them special advantage and some
special environment and whether they
kind of snout on a
dog better to be able to dig in the
ground some little vine that just could
grow up the Amazon do it very
beautifully our birds flying in the sky
with beautiful wings but when not flying
unable to disencumber themselves the
wings because the integral therefore
walking was a difficult matter for the
bird
so I said humans then don't have these
building special equipments a lot of
people identify brain with humans but
there many creatures have brains and I
found that brains yes if you want to
think about it your own direct
experience brains are always and only
coordinating the information of the
senses without which we don't are not
hardly unaware of universal and so
they're coordinating the special cases
this one smells a little different from
that one so we have packages of the
specialties experiences which brains are
able to to store and retrieve memory are
I found humans had a special capability
that not manifest by any other creature
called which I called mine because I
just heard mind and brain it's an
exchange without now differentiating
clearly brains this physical equipment
for coordinating the senses and mind
from time to time had a capability to
discover relationships existing between
special cases that didn't were not
manifest by any special cases considered
only by themselves as for instance wrong
throwing a case of human beings being
excited by the night sky those seemingly
fixed stars recognizable constellations
encounter distinctions they were 1 2 3
from time to time lights that appeared a
little bit bigger brighter than the
others and moved in a that you couldn't
seem in the moving against things but
tonight there and they'll different
position from yesterday so quite clearly
they were moving around but later on
begin to call the planets and these are
so intriguing to humanity that they made
all kinds of speculations they kept
records of them as best they could
relation to their periods of seasons and
other experiences
and they gave them names of gods but not
until human beings have calculating
capability which is really very very
recent far as humanity and general goals
which came along with the positioning of
numbers and and the ability then to
multiply and divide if you ever tried
doing your calculations in Roman
numerals who find how difficult it is
the fact you can't get anywhere at all
and so not until then these Arabic
numerals came in and the cypher itself
and it gets publication written in
northern Africa in 1512 hundred then
took 300 years where to get into Italy
in northern southern Germany
the point where Copernicus as a human
being has calculated capability and with
calculating capability in taking the
data regarding what renew of these
planets and suddenly discovers that
we're one of those planets going around
the Sun the Sun is not going around us I
want to really stress how very very
recent is that event because I find
today though is 500 years ago we're
really not and we know everybody knows
about it we have done very little to get
ourselves actually celebrating reacting
in terms of it
Princessa I had way great honor being
writer to speak to the MIT faculty club
back in in early 50s and the I was the
the Dean of architecture of that time it
was said to me that he he found that the
architectural department is never being
asked to give any faculty club talks
because MIT felt that is so really MIT
that architecture of the boundary sort
of a department of liaison with idiots
and that
so they they were not really taken very
seriously so he complains of the other
Dean's about it and they said alright
you you have the next faculty lecture
and and he though they Dean asked me to
give the talk and because I knew about
his saying about the fact that the
family who lives on with idiots I I said
that the faculty club when I stood up I
was very surprised to be asked to speak
to them because I was also ignorant they
look very surprised and I had to make
good in a hurry I said any of you
present who do not see the Sun going
down in the evening let me show your
hands there were no hands I said you've
had five hundred years you've known the
Sun is not going down for five hundred
years what are you doing in your
education system about coordinating your
senses with your information well I
think it's very ignorant to persist in
this manner keep bouncing you're very
practical to say sunrise and sunset
simply rather good poetry but you keep
continually standing your kids off with
misinformation that is enough of that
particular episode but I'm coming back
now to trying to identify humans and I
said we have this phenomenon mind and we
have this matter then our planets the
idea of suddenly that with the we're
when the planets going around the Sun
and this enormous Lee intrigue others
and have Tycho Brahe getting better
instruments being man rate means and
making some better observations he needs
a mathematician getting Kepler and
Kepler then discovering that all these
different planets were different this is
from the Sun all different sizes all
going around at different rates so while
they're all the same team seem to be
very disorderly but being a
mathematician he said I know one thing
in common which is they're going around
the Sun at least that I could as a
mathematician give them something else
in common I might be able to find radium
or out how to knowns
so he said I'm going to give them an
only says I'm going to give them so many
days
as I remember it was 21 days and giving
them exactly 21 days right to the second
he knew where each one was in respect to
the sound of the sound you know the
distances from the Sun you knew they by
this time to discover the moving
elliptical arcs so he then had the
radius from the Sun of the start and
then a different radius little different
radius at the end of the 21 days you
knew exactly then what he was able to
make a diagram each one of these radius
new radius and the elliptical out and
having this these pictures now triangles
long thin triangles said I could have
all the dynamite as well calculate these
areas well there doesn't seem to be any
triangles in the sky might as well do
that and if you were kepler and and then
make this calculation as discovered they
were not similar but they were exactly
the same think of it the astonishment of
a human being that hidden in this great
superficial disorder was in his elegant
mathematical coordination obviously
coordinated to come out exactly the same
all of them so that he then had to think
in a way that you and I have never had
no other human beings ever had the thing
before because he could he doesn't tell
you this in a diary but supposing they
were touching each other he could made
to understand how they might move like
gears to coordinate but they were
millions of miles and five minutes a
miles apart and human beings had no idea
of anything operating millions of miles
apart and way of attention and
absolutely invisible some kind of
visible tendon operating here st. if we
think about the intellectual challenge
that really was but he he was familiar
to human being and swing a weight around
your head it stays in orbit if you like
let go it goes off and in a line also
he's familiar if you want to make it and
lips you have to use two restraints
instead of one restraint so he had to
assume somehow rather because he'd found
they're moving elliptically there was
there were some kind of restraints of
tensions operating over millions of
miles and the fact that they the planets
bunch from time to time made me them
possibly pull on the bunch could pull on
the run as
son and so we had he made those kind of
sonar discoveries now here we have
suddenly some in relationship existing
between there's not manifested in any
run there's nothing and then any one
planet have said they agree strings to
another planet isn't going to get out
and talk about only because there was a
group with behaving this way that
humanity ever paid an attention and my
family were a team they're having a
little differently from all the rest of
the universe you finally discovers some
relationship going on there there's go
we go on from that Galileo measuring the
rate of falling bodies acceleration of
the rate of falling and getting the
mathematics of that and we have Isaac
Newton tremendously eager to understand
but this extraordinary invisible tension
was that Kepler had had now discovered
and have Isaac Newton and finally being
able to work out factor the
interrelationship the inter the inter
attractiveness was varying it's the
second power of the Allis medical
distances apart but the inverse ratio of
it that's how the distance between the
two you increased it went to fourfold if
you double the distance apart it went
down one quarter other before suddenly
we then have a human mind able then have
discovered the mathematical relationship
which hypothesis hypothetical but then
is tested and tested and tested by
astronomers and always explaining the
celestial into the inter practice these
celestial bodies but whatever bodies he
was studying
so this Bradley became what we call a
mathematical generalization a scientific
generalization and found no exceptions
whatsoever and they could only be
expressed mathematically so he suddenly
found human mind having a capability
from time to time
discover relationship existing between
which can only be expressed
mathematically Italian intellectual
matter and we have then I said brain
dealing in the special cases and the
special cases were always always
temporal had
beginnings and endings and but we have
suddenly human mind discovering these
principles and I say if they qualify the
generalized principle means they have no
exceptions and that was how no
exceptions must be inherently eternal
there's nothing to say that one of these
these generalizations may not someday
prove to have a conception but as far as
we know there is a family of them today
which we have no except so therefore we
absolutely time we find the exception
they must be considered in heavenly
eternal and it's very different the
human brain then asking for beginnings
in energy of universe and human mind
having capability to discover that which
is eternal I became very intrigued then
by the idea of the what we call and
behaviors of whole systems like the
planetary systems solar system in which
the the behavior of the whole is not
explained by behavior of any of the
paths considered only separately we call
that synergetic so that began to sink
and about universe and those kind of
terms and saying how many of these
generalized krisily discovered we as we
discover one we don't know we're going
to discover it but suddenly to have it
nor do we know it whether it's going to
be the last one that would be discovered
we don't know how many there are or this
is it there is an increasing inventory
and now there's a principle of leverage
the mathematics of that and as Galileo
showed the you didn't have to have a
compression level and Confessional
fulcrum you could have a tension fulcrum
you could have pulleys and and and and
he falls carrying out the same
mathematics and so there are beautiful
mathematical laws which ours
generalization that human beings could
abuse objectively as special cases
now this then gave me and I the feeling
that humans were had a very different
kind of function in universal good
didn't know any other phenomena had
access to these extraordinary
generalized principles because when you
and I use the word design we immediately
would infer a an intellectual sorting
and deliberate arrangement otherwise
we're design seems to be then
involves a complex of that to be sorted
and to be ranged and best we can see
then these human minds have been
discovering these generalized principles
and I said what is very impressive about
them is not only being eternal now
they're all concurrently operative but
they none of them have ever been found
to contradict any dozens and several
several Narender augmentative so some
totally I found human mind apparently
being admitted to some of the great
design of universe itself so we must be
very important we have this kind of this
kind of access that therefore we're now
trying to understand vibrated about this
planet had to think about in the
universe itself I want also wants you to
think about the very strong Airy change
in the phenomena concept of universe
just in my day when I was 28 Hubble
discovered another galaxy pretty strong
even called it galaxy because we had a
galactic sickness Milky Way our galactic
system and Sun is another galaxy
today we know or two billion galaxies
this cell give you an idea a rate of
expansion of what you and I have to
consider as universe so but you
spontaneously in your day
think about universe is vastly greater
than anything I had to think about its
universe and that gives you again the
sense of the very incredible
acceleration of knowing that's going to
take place with humanity itself now
thinking about then this function of
helium humans in universe also said one
of the things that very impressive is
that human beings are all born always
born naked absolutely helpless for
months beautiful equipment but
absolutely ignorant because no
experience so that that will
deliberately born that way even though
as our eyes were designed or just our
brains design with a quadrillion atoms
in coordinate send you not can
communicate that's all a priori and so
strongly down that we do we sort of take
it to menace if it granted and and and
don't only very recently begin to really
take some kind of cognizance of the fact
that this is such incredible technology
that we don't
call it technology because it's way
beyond the the kind of grasp humans so
far have of Technology the kind of
offense which we've employed up today
now thinking now I've traveled from this
point on I'm trying to identify why
humans are in universe and what we might
be able to do about coming on a betting
with nature our universe quite as
universe have us here and trying to abet
the realization of that function and
view of the fact we're always born naked
helpless and ignorant and the relatively
short time we know our being on board up
here from about about a three million
years it's amazing to me how human
beings thing being born naked helped us
signet but hungry thirsty curious driven
to make Moo's hungry trying out this and
somebody right either Barry and the dial
for then thousand years that time said
nobody can eat berries then suddenly
discover some berries gonna need some
you couldn't and they sure didn't have
any any manual operating manual she
could pick you out of had green safe to
even read dangerously if she wanted to
but you didn't do in that way she
deliberately sought foster to learn by
trial and error I seem to be a
deliberate part of the design so we've
had to make incredible number of
mistakes in those three million years or
more and we've got now the point where
we have discovered so many 150,000
nuances of experience which is so unique
that they require their own worlds and
we were green on those words there's an
amazing amount of ingredients to
agreements are very difficult so I found
that here we have an enormous facility
of communication one another and we are
there's a suddenly come to point where
we did to get that communication we then
began to accumulate information very
very rapidly and I felt that all this
had to do with all of us being born in
the sort of group womb of permitted
ignorance an enormous amount of
resources with by which which we could
by trial and error
learn something about why we're here in
universe and to me then the most
absolutely important thing about is our
minds clearly and muscle is nothing
muscle we don't we can't compete with a
donkey and we mean you get think about
about the energies in our universe that
I make so rather quick quick summary of
two things as the as we know during
during my lifetime just in this century
began discoveries that chemical animals
have unique frequencies when
incandescent in an arc flame which could
be detected by the spectroscope and we
have now using the light from the coming
from the two billion galaxies we've been
able to take that light and run it
through the spectroscope and on but one
of our planet little human beings have
an inventory of the relative abundance
of all the chemical chemical elements
present within 11 1/2 billion light
years around us human mind can has that
kind of scope of capability but I saw
nothing and yet muscle and cunning and
still in control of human affairs so
this is very this is why we are in
regulate characters we hear quite
clearly for our minds and minds are not
in control now I will come back to some
things that hit me very hard and of
great significance for instance in the
Navy where I had then commander of a
ship and I've been so taught that I
could take over the job of my senior I
could take over the ship I could take
over the fleet of necessary the whole
training was that way all leading up to
a moment I'll contact and destruction I
wondered when I'll buy all this
extraordinary technology beautiful
science been produced testing work to
destruction and this brought me them to
the discovery of the fact that for up
to 1500 we've been really thinking about
all the universe as a flattened
University even though there were
individuals who have quite sure our
world was a sphere but there that was
anything but popular generative thing
about everything was a flat earth the
Ptolemaic map of going going back to
really 3,000 years as it was with
fitting took in all all of Europe North
Africa and Asia and serviced a
rectangular form then came to the
wilderness and went on to infinity and
but it's a flat world and this is true
of all the great empires of Charlemagne
never going Roman Empire want anyone the
Genghis Khan all of those empires its
flattened Empire going to infinity and
if if you didn't like the way things are
viewed there are infinite number of gods
and infinite numbers Chancellor you came
out all right you afraid so it's worth
playing and right we have suddenly we
have Sonny Magellan and thus coming
round a spherical earth and have the the
most powerful people of these times and
learn that he were to call the control
of the world wealth was by virtue of the
controlling of the great waterways I'm
going to I'd like to extend that little
cuz you are MIT and we have
archaeologically the city-state being
discovered over and over again greatness
we're all cities Mycenae in rhesus a
good example of it the beautiful fertile
valley great run around with mountains
in the middle of the great high hill and
that high hill you could see all the all
the facets coming into this and you
could look at all the great fertile
fields command the old show
then you had by building great walls
around the top of that hill and then
Rawls going down to a world for the well
you have a very safe sizzle when you saw
enemy coming you then took all the foods
from the valley and brought them inside
the walls that you could but you
couldn't bring in you could I think all
the Scotch they've burned about so when
the enemy came in all the the local
people had all the food and sign there
at all the water the people who came
hungry and they can undergo 30 days
without food without getting very weak
and then when they get a good week and
ground decimate them and this is this is
rather the city state of the very
successful invention for thousands of
years but the meantime humans began to
build with three crosses covers of water
going from just dugouts and and rafts
and the Sun are getting two rib ships
with rib ships got bigger and bigger and
get the point of about the open time in
Mycenae our even Creed II and Creed II
island of Crete there's no fortification
because this is the headquarters the
water people there's been bigger than
bigger boats and we have then the
Mycenaeans going in there big boats up
to Troy and Troy commanding the the
traffic from Asia into Europe those
extraordinary point completely we were
all sitting so they have all their food
inside when the enemy comes expect the
people outside the star but suddenly
there's these great ships they could go
off and get more supplies continually
bring supplies this we call the minor
supply and it then it just I fell we
then from this point on history begins
there where the very powerful people
control and the biggest control has been
controlling great lines of supply this
shows up very much to get Italy where
you see all those beautiful fertile
valleys lovely cast sellers commanding
the valleys but there's one city in
Italy very different Venice in no walls
whatsoever because water people and the
water people then took their ships all
around Italy and brought up lines and
supplying they stopped all the people
out of the Costello this is great
changer over fundamentals of humanity so
we have suddenly the gentleman going
around the world and those who control
the great lines of supply between the
the Europe and Asia who had enormous
resources great wealth had already been
developed to bring that wealth to Europe
and cash in on it
enormous ambitions to do that these
ambitions are operated under the names
of different countries like France and
Portugal but they really great powerful
individuals Queen Elizabeth the first
found Sir HT the company in 1600
yesterday after about three quarter
century after Magellan gets around and
she then there's a private private
prizes some of the private friends and
able to protect it with her whether her
Empire's capability there's an enormous
battle by eight about Battle of
Trafalgar 1805 with suddenly the British
Empire is it and it was said to be the
first empire which the Sun never set in
order to carry on develop that Empire
that also develop then the eastern they
come to college in England which is
still their campus still operating very
beautiful campus and on that campus in
eighteen hundred writing just before
Trafalgar five years before on five
years after two different books have
Thomas Malthus who is a professor of
economics he's seen their company
college and he is the first individual
in history to have total vital
statistics from around a closed system
earth to that he seen the company
college at all these servants all around
we're picking up the critical
information so suddenly he had this
incredible information and he's able to
write 1800 and 1810 to confirm it there
quite clearly humanity with mother plank
sever the geometrical rate who does it
producing life support only an era
sabbatical rate and quite clearly
humanity majority you manage design to
be a failure pay all you want won't do
any because this isn't anymore so this
is a very formidable piece of
information for those who are in the
know but it was everybody general
illiteracy very few people was not a
popular piece of knowledge at all but is
the information of those who were in
powerful positions making that critical
decision for humanity we have then
thirty-five years later Darwin for Mel
getting his theory of evolution and and
suggesting then survive alone of the
fittest as a fundamental cause of it
then we have the economists saying
alright we like that but I'm and said I
was not then that not about this in
economics that did not mean the
economists said well if it's our case
perfectly then we have Karl Marx and
English saying he now accepts Malthus
has pure science is a closed system
there's a closed system
Hans fat and we have Darwin survival on
the face so town mark said quite clearly
the worker is fittest to survive because
he knows how to handle the tools to make
all the products how to grow
seasoning these other people to paradise
that people said we obviously not
parasites
top of the heap because they work as
their so now we need some really bright
people around here make some instrument
one kind of long distance vision
visionary speculations so we have then
since that time and closed system us
instead of flat errors where the
Sunday's instead of being dichotomy of
different kinds of religions we have we
have the Sally the socialist viewpoint
and and the and the and there and they
are now an enterprise it's very various
degrees between the two but we have
since that time on our planet the great
ideology is saying you may not like on
system personally but we're convinced we
have the fairest most logical most
ingenious way of coping with lesson and
adequacy of life support but because
there are those who disagree
diametrically on how to cope you can
only be resolved by trial of arms which
system is fitted to survive and that's
the reason for instance of Russia and
nine states through the last thirty
years have been propagating over two
hundred billion dollars a year total now
over six trillion dollars been
appropriate to buying highest ability
humanity and focus it on how destroy
most accurately most effectively a
greater and greater this is swifter and
Swifter this is very senior I could
incredibly poor investment although we
really learned then right that's right
it's gone
I'm worried about time they're trying to
think how to get everything I really
need to get to notice numbers of
ministry anyway but I had guns
experience I said to here I'm and
Cambridge to the boy and suddenly having
this Wireless come in Sunday's read
airplanes coming in and I said I really
feel something and what was really
coming in was from a what we call a
visible reality everything reality when
I was Leon was everything you could see
smell touch in here that's reality
and they said you if you're sane and and
you're healthy you know just what you're
doing suddenly this is upset very much
by Freud in amazement
discovering great many things we did we
didn't know but just what we're doing
anyway
when I was young it was really exactly I
said you knew just what you're doing you
can smell it touch it see and hear it
can't you
now I realized something was coming in
with your called an invisible reality
because suddenly there was here I'll
renounce three years of age the
electrons discovered didn't make any
newspaper nobody knows that's going to
be anything and suddenly there were
these alloys and we're suddenly bringing
by virus by really accident all the only
great alloy discoveries by metal edges
have been really accidental up to time
of the space program after World War two
and so we have then alloys and then
alloy such fit I just give you in terms
of aluminum which arrived dramatically
clear aluminum is we learn to refine
electrolytically on in there and the
night is but we don't really use it for
anything but it was a souvenir
ashtrays and things like that after the
nineteen thirties when it goes in the
airplane for the first time and the
aluminum and but what amuses the obvious
property giving the greatest
- - the strength of material is his
ability so here not be pulled apart and
so we call the tensile strength per
square inch or whatever section we want
and so the tensile strength of the pure
alumina was 18,000 pounds of square inch
we learned and accidentally a little
complicated into and so forth
and get up suddenly to double that
straight to 36,000
then during this World War two the
Japanese brought in another alloy got up
to 72,000 pounds of square meters so I
could have three rods of aluminum here
one inch in diameter say three feet long
all the way the same no scientists could
look at them tell any difference
whatsoever and this one is double the
strength of this and it's double again
now here was something coming into World
War one that I being in regular line
line officer became tremendous aware of
and was then up to this time everybody
knew their spies could see the size
ships they're building took a long time
to build a ship it would take then the
total Cubans and the weight of that
water that that that tributed water was
all the ship could weigh everything he
had on board but suddenly I saw will
grow more on that ship is coming at you
and has the same tonnage as your ship
has the same number of guns same size
guns but yet this you don't know when
it's coming at you is metal it's much
stronger than for shoot fire much
further away and this became the most
highly classified a secret information
in World War one was the alloys are
doing is it something we had an
invisible reality and the public
couldn't tell about it's very easy to
keep secret couldn't see good no way to
understand so one ship went to the
bottom and they couldn't tell anything
about it and so there's a very easy to
keep that kind of secret
I I became fascinated then World War one
to realize that we're beginning to do
more with the same and more with less
and I could see it was coming in many
different ways in electronics that
motorists didn't know he assumed if you
need it had a message go across romantic
had to send a ship it's going to take 40
50 days he didn't know how to go and
have a little piece of apparatus like do
it and if 186,000 miles a second I said
how many things did mouths us leave out
so I began to keep lists of it by 1917 I
really late 97 have become really very
sight of to realize there was something
going on in humanity here which it had
me intuitively curious anyway we're
we're doing more with less invisibly and
it might be some day where you do so
much with so little it might be possible
that North us is wrong might be enough
for everybody if we did enough this is
at every challenging idea as a kid that
really get into the sea
it could be true I came out of the Navy
were in the building world I stayed in
that building world for five years and
and I found it thousands of years behind
the Arts of the environment controlling
the sea in the sky I just finsihed point
out to well have you talked about how
much you know exactly what Boeing 747
weighs loaded three tons and a rate of
climb how many people's yeah no
everything's you can do out of every
pound of material you put in every ounce
of materials out every egg of energy
every second of time but you ask people
what buildings where they don't know
where the buildings right if you don't
know what buildings where you're sitting
you don't have any way to ratio
performance so just want to get an idea
of the building world on the land being
thousands of years behind that other see
in the sky you know exactly what you're
getting out of every ounce have to know
and so I I became excited to realize
that it was in the building world that
we're really behind because there's
something called priorities and in in
relation to the military if the heads of
state then are going to have to protect
themselves against other states they're
going to defend themselves there's not
enough that around them it's all of that
then they leave things their military to
defend them
military say well alright we now know
that they're these chemical elements and
they're so much mercury this summer's
helium and they do something absolutely
unique that nothing else will do who has
access to these absolutely unique
high-performance materials who has
access to the unique very high
performance with special instruments and
tools production to rate well trained
brains obviously then you have something
had priority of access to the high
performance capabilities the military
had that they spent then if you have
priority after anti priority who has to
make do with the low performance or no
performance at all because obviously the
homefront not enough for people anyway
letting poor devils to get on the best
they can I saw that the human beings
being beautiful human beings and trying
to make the best of life didn't get up
an architecture that was to them these
attractive how doesn't make do where we
have them big and heavy they think of
the world the more secure that I did
went out even in architecture along with
the the Maginot Line and right up to
them is you controlled yourself that way
the big and heavy and high the walls are
more secure used to have all the
advertisers now is young about great
insurance company was strongest or
safest of Rock of Gibraltar which they
don't use that advertisers anymore now
what I cited me in 1927 I've been in
this building world and finally no
scientist ever even asked to look at the
plumbing a sacred notice scientist ever
done anything about the plumber you have
you have beautiful courses here on on
frictions and pipes and things like that
but nobody's redesigning the plumbing
here we have the human beings every one
of you several times a day taking this
beautiful Sun evaporation water getting
the sky and coming down absolutely pure
to us and we take that beautiful water
and we use four and five gallons
several times a day to get rid of a pint
of yellow
how much sense of that amazin and rather
just say just no no the home front was
absolutely thousand years behind the art
of the sea in the sky
so in 1927 the American Institute of
Architects as they do today had it that
journal and the journal they're
published buildings they thought well
I'll and they had a single-family
dwelling in Illinois in 1927 which they
thought was optimum for under the
conditions of 1927 I took that total
floor area total cubed total number
windows and lumens of light that could
get in everything it had equipment to do
listen to all the performance
capabilities and I took his total weight
including the pipes out of the mains
came out 150 tons then taking the having
the masses same cubed same number
Florence floor area every performance
capability of the single-family dwelling
Illinois but using the most advanced
aircraft design at the time it came out
only three tons so I've said three times
get 150 if we really began to set of
waiting which was going on in those days
I saw after the military developed
something then suddenly became obsolete
that particular weapon and people who
all tooled up to produce this kind of
equipment then look around the home
front for some out load this is how
princessy refrigeration which we'd had
in the Navy for 25 years suddenly came
up in the land the twenties and suddenly
didn't have to have ice in your box
there and so I some others have fall out
they came very secondarily very
languidly maybe a quarter of a century
maybe half a century later came into the
home front
began to change the standard of living
and in the terms of its just in my day
we've grown from less than one for
sanity bounded to 56 percent of humanity
enjoying a higher standard of living
today then was known and experienced by
any potent day when I was gone and
during that time we double the
population so actually 112 folded the
number being benefited by the advanced
technology but all is a very slow
feedback from the preoccupation with how
to kill
so I said supposing we didn't wait for
that but looked at the home front right
away and it might be i was indicated by
this three tons get 150 that maybe we
could really get doing semester so
little we could really demonstrate to
humanity that really isn't enough to go
around so that was 52 years ago and I
have been engaged in that direction ever
since and then now I had brought me
across into geodesic structures and
where I could do very much smaller and
much less and they're now over two
hundred thousand somewhere around the
world they're in very remote places
where very highest kind of performance
required where other kinds of structures
would just would not do whether they're
ringing the new line that's raid owns
our experimental station over the South
Pole or whether raid on top of Mount
Fuji able to withstand an extraordinary
hurricanes and gales snow loads so
delicate that microwaves can go through
yet so light that one helicopter took it
up then just fast in place like a great
bird landing so I've had enough
experience in the logistics of
environment controlling and a factor
also I've been carrying on since 1927
but I call the world world game instead
of the Navy game of world war games
where the people in the land was not
concerned but the neighbors concerned
with the streak was versus water and
they then how is going to who's going to
get live control of the line of supply
that's the old story and how many
resources other around the world the
whole training of Navy was still in
those things and how I said I'm gonna
play a game called world game not world
war game where I look at the sum total
and see how I can use it if possible to
make all humanity success you seem to be
indicated as implicit in this trending
of doing more with less now so I've kept
all kinds of curves
I kept the curves or the rate of
increase of the tensile strength and the
Steel's and and they then got in the
luminance found that I could predictably
luminal curve word for word and it did
etc etc and right keeping enough track
of all the total dollar I've been able
then to be able to say certain things
right ten years ago I was able to and by
actually design able to say it is now
incontrovertibly evidence' Belen
engineering that we within 10 years our
design revolution we're using only
proven technology using only metals
already mind that recirculating we
please feasible within 10 years to have
all humanity at a high living at highest
and living and any humans have ever
known before on a sustainable basis
because during the same ten years we can
phase out forever
all further use fossil fuels and atomic
energy we can live in Townley and our
energy income and this became as they
encounter a very definite demonstrable
for instance I've just taken the N and
his energy side we have a book which is
called I've published by our world game
energy earth and everyone you'll be able
to get copies of it from from Doubleday
in July the first printings winter we're
exhausted and they the title went from
the straight our press of San Francisco
to Simon's sister soldiers and Doubleday
in Doubleday been very slow I'm bringing
Albert it would be out of your life you
find absolutely incontrovertible I
though they live on our energy income
the incident I just like to mention the
following to you as a world of
technology and it will draw to the grand
strategy against Hitler was then cut off
his energy and they were able to then
bomb fluorescent so foes immediately
German scientists read the word and they
learned how to keep that economy going
on their energy income from the tundra
from the vegetation they were able to
enter go in the fall the four kinds of
alcohols with Grand Central Station of
energy and from there they can get if
you may remember they also developed the
very high-performance rubber and said
having the ten thousand mount hours got
up to fifty thousand all they did this
all our alcohol now coming to tally from
vegetation they were able then to
produce high octane gas gasoline were
able to produce food and they kept the
economy going
it's very amazing to me that the rest of
the United States rushing in and say
they didn't Berlin and I because I was
in the broader economic welfare and I
know we had
that data none of this data been brought
out of the energy mentions here once it
allows why does not come out well the
next thing I've discovered having made a
statement such that I've just made to
you been able to make it ten years ago
and make it have been making it publicly
ever since you get checked up and says
statements and I've I've possibly over
thousand really quite confident people
have checked over my dollar and find
it's correct they may be about a million
people who were credit those thousand
and so out there but their fraud billion
human beings so humanity doesn't know
this but there is an increasing number
who know that's possible now the next
thing I discovered was that all big
government which is political all big
politics all big religion all big
business founded after devastating the
activity to have humanities success
they're all predicated on human being
trouble
come to me
join outside get a little better deals
your people come here I comfort you and
get you in heaven all the different
things everything predicated on man
being in great pain trouble so then I
realize that while there may be
individuals who might be very excited by
anything you as your little individual
might do and we're finding who better
way of some sun energy and pounding
because it all does come with all comes
from the Sun that they pay lip-service
you but big government you under nothing
balance so I mean and to say what are
our odds here with here we come to new
new knowledge first time in history we
don't have to be afraid if we don't have
to be afraid in but it does it doesn't
have to be you and me ever again it
doesn't have to be any war you don't
have to rationalize surfaces don't have
rats turns why your family is little
more deserving than the other fellas
family that's why you should see the
other guy just think that we again in
that kind of relationship to universe
then right I said that does not seem to
me to be unreasonable I saw that
hydrogen atom doesn't have to earn a
living for behaving like a hydrogen that
in fact the only only function is come
into universe we know we're had to do
this
you were meaning as I know as a human
beings and all the rest of the universal
working extraordinarily it generally
regenerative the only hundreds an
efficient system you know so this then
brought me that observing everything
else i coordinate evolutions going on
I'll give you some very big evolutionary
event historically humans like other
mammals the female carrying the young
can't cover as much geography annually
as can the male
the North American wolf allergy to very
much greater sweep out the male grausens
female and so we have the humans and the
human female man learn to get that fire
going and she could then keep the the
food last plastic as long as you learn
how to to dry out to do distressing
she's sitting around the heart
preserving because I'll
the man was a hunter he bring in new
kind of creature she will decide whether
the skin it or milk it and so gradually
the man not only was a hunter but he
also was the news bringer because he got
to the top of the mountain than the
other people hadn't been there so to the
it all the children through history mom
and dad were the authority and what
you're gonna eat but that what that dad
and mom had found that you could eat
what the chieftain would put up with and
so forth dad and mom with authority for
this new little life here not only that
but Dad will in addition was he was the
news man and as language is very
inadequate very poor over the great ages
but anyway what he'd seen from the top
of the mountain or he'd heard that the
chieftain said and his language was very
probably the kids then that is its
hourly and this way dad says it so the
esoteric way of communication went to
the kids alright but it started more and
more dialects and different languages
suddenly we have when I said the
electron come in and I'm three-year I
was I was 23 we have the human voice on
the radio here I was 27 we have the
first licensed broadcasting radio
station 1927 all the daddies were coming
home one evening and all the kids said
daddy come in listening radio a man
flying across the Atlantic and daddy
never brought the news home ever again
it stopped nobody thought about this
anthropological ascent me saw the news
of it and if you're preoccupied with the
news but the fact was then the people
who got that job on the radio
got it by virtue of the commonality of
the addiction rather special esoteric
way the daddy said it and they've dated
by which was the size of vocabulary and
the versatility in employing it that's
where they got their jobs and to
maintain them and there's liquidity in
which they could get it out so the kids
then saw dad and mom let's take that
radio and they saw dad run across the
street town with a mate rate radio man
who said so quite clearly these were dad
and mom in this hour they
but these are Margaret Authority could
an imam learning from them so the kids
then emulated the words the way this
great authority said it this completely
changed the speech pattern of humanity
one of the things I've lived through is
that change I'll show you here in Boston
my first job before World War one I work
with some very expert craftsmen very
fine human beings they're very lovable
but their vocabulary is about a hundred
was 50% blasphemous or I've seen mainly
the way they spit and let you know how
they feel about them that this is really
change is incredible to me I now have
been around the world 44 times and the
vocabulary around the world of this
extraordinary I can really use her very
best like I have in me and I found this
how being understood very readily now
this is all changed in our lifetime and
came about by virtue of that radio and
getting some commonality of diction at
some point now the next thing that
happens is they nobody said to the kids
this great authoritative simply is
self-evident that this is a great
Authority now and the kid instinctively
found with the great Authority the child
wants to know so then what do as you
know the speed of sound
approximately 700 miles an hour speed of
light approximately 700 million miles
inner function million times faster and
then you sound only operates in our
atmosphere and then the light goes right
on the amount of information you get
visually relations what you get through
your here is is a midden phone so sunny
we have the young students at Berkeley
County University of California making
the world news as the center's about the
educational system and that particular
group asked me to come and meet with
them and I met their contemporary as
many universities that year they they
graduated and the majority of them
graduated
66 this is them suddenly I found those
kids were born the year the television
came in the America now and they're all
said I know the dad and mom love me to
pieces I loved that amount of pieces but
what's going on has a slight idea what's
going on they don't have anything to do
without going to Korea are going through
the moon they don't have anything they
just love human beings with the world is
in trouble and this information we gain
from around the world not just locally
anymore way I guess gotta have very
local information I was young
they're really getting world news Will's
in trouble the older people don't know
what's going on I've got to do my own
thinking now I'll show you one of the
things that was very different about
this and when I was young my father died
I was right young my mother said I'm
going to send you best school I can
afford to do I don't have very much
money we're going to brunch it and she
said darling never mind her to think
listen to me trying to teach you I went
to school and said never mind was just
saying listen we're trying to teach her
weekend attended Tony no never mind what
you're saying I was also being told my
men as I got older that life is right
outside to be you and me so you got to
get over all your sensitivity get always
sense everything in mind two things
right I found myself out of gear with it
all so there's sort of a game that's out
of them and so I learned the game as
best I could but nobody's saying the
young world anymore never mind to think
there's just none of it and suddenly
have a young world 19 just going back
then to the sixties where if suddenly a
young will start doing his own thinking
it's very new at it very idealistic with
Russia in those states spending 200
million a year on how did a story about
they appropriated about 20 billion a
year a 10% of it on how to break down
the other man's economy before you get
to the war and that's it so the United
States had free press was very easy very
much easy to operate against and then
was the Russian side where they didn't
have free press I heard the residents
say they said to me many time can't
understand why you keep it free press
cuz we can send it get a bonfire going
in America goes all over the place and
right we have then there's no question
about the young people who very
idealistic being exploited by very
ingeniously and so there was all kind of
activism then in the 60s then suddenly
kids found they were using their heads
for battering rams they said I sort of
use my head for thinking now for
battering ram so they began to develop
an immunization to the being exploitable
so today they're nowhere
nearly I find each year finally
regulators I have been a visitor now and
550 university colleges around the world
many of the college of many times like
MIT and almost innumerable times I'm
going to have quite a good feeling for
you to tell you that there is very great
strength in that young world today doing
its own thinking and realizing it is in
an invisible world and and you only have
to have competence to really carry on in
the invisible world the invisible
reality so officially it's what you have
here at MIT all places so next thing I
saw was a each child being born
successively was being born the presence
of less misinformation and he still
child being born successfully being born
in the presence of much more reliable
information now I saw that I'm I'm
getting letters today not frequently but
I get them say four or five a year from
eight and ten year olds have been born
after man got to the moon and how they
find that I'm something they can write
to I don't know what they do
the letters are beautifully written and
they say humanity can do anything needs
to do why don't we make this thing work
they're completing full of full of
concern about it nicely nature is coming
through with something new here and
we're capable in it and so I gave you
also I'm being born they could help the
Signet haven't learned by trial and
error humanity then getting the point
where I did develop words did gain a
whole lot of information but made an
incredible number misinterpretation
about we take a polished steel ball 16
inches in diameter it would probably be
rougher than our earth planet pictures
taken of our planet coming in from outer
space we've seen through the cloud cover
you can see the blue water the brown
land and you can't see mountains let
alone human beings human beings are you
not standing on top of one another sad
banging a chain take 10,000 us to make
the difference between that emotion in
the most points about Earth so you know
I want 10,000 invisible our planet Earth
is diameter about 1/100 out of the Sun
if you look at the sun's an afternoon
when this crowd in front of his white
this take coins out of your pocket I'm
like to try to cover it if I'm a nickel
just about covers it you'll find that
the size with about that's against that
our school rulers remember sixteenth of
an inch but engineering said get down to
fifty a hundredth of an inch but being
on there everything gets blurred to have
the very finest printing where seemingly
absolute continuity read in the colors
you have two hundredths of an inch
been right I planned it as it's so small
against the Sun its unites it you
couldn't see it so you and I are
invisible on our planet and I plant
invisible against the Sun which is
rather inferior star we have a hundred
billion stars in our galaxy and let's
look at Orion's belt in there too to
write styles they're running Bellinger's
it's not it's diameter is greater than
the orbit of the earth around the Sun so
there's a good sized star all right but
understand we have a very small star we
run a hundred billion stars in our
galaxy we now know of two billions as
galaxies obviously that kind of universe
is not interesting where the republicans
or democrats are being elected
you know is it interested in our
baseball news anything else we are not
planted here as they're talking factory
insanity in relation to our universe so
I saw the nature then did this cut off
where she had all of us this group womb
and with all the resources by trial and
error to get enough information to get
the point where he makes them completely
new judgments the kind of information I
luckily happen to be just a functioning
rat did come to it we now know there's
enough to go around
it's clearly the monster well at which
point we really have to have a
completely new generation so I see when
nature has a child in the room that you
have a child has to have oxygen but
mother's out where the action is so she
does a breathing gets it in the
bloodstream have an umbilical cord to
get to the child when the child comes
out you cut the umbilical cord
now get its own I think nature then had
what I call a metaphysical cord she had
a rather the older people telling the
younger ones what they've been able to
find out to accumulate things to get
some words to get get a working style
but we got to the point where so many
misinterpretation of the significance
have been made that at the time that
came for a cut-off
so she suddenly have this young will cut
off a dessa I don't want to get apt to
me is it enormous enormous evolutionary
event incredibly big event that a young
world is suddenly doing the thinking as
I said I brought up here never all the
old world is assuming the keeper
thinking capabilities absolutely
unreliable so here we are in this new
chapter and I could see that there may
be that young the new young is coming
through but really take over and things
becoming less and less tenable now we
found quite a long time ago the great
religions realize they could not stay
operating just within 150 pens of
Nations
they became transnational then found all
big business found that they were owned
transaction taking all the money out of
America incidentally and so we have that
the Americans have 150 people have four
billion people in 150 pens
subject to drafting and
anybody any big powers can usually just
throw you up against their enemy whether
you like it or not but we under
condition our first fortunately we've
discovered this crap recirculation we
don't have to do any mining and that's
crap recirculation we have 150 pans we
really have 150 blood clots for the
economics to really work of the
recirculating regenerative universe
which were planning ourselves in
Saturday yesterday looking out just this
way we now discover ecology oh really
the whole system is regenerative so
we've found enormous regenerate system
universe itself where things are going
off like that rather than front of us I
then just feel that there's a great
great possibility that this younger
world will very quickly reject something
I'm going to run some slides for you now
because I want to get the sense of
acceleration and some other big
evolutionary events may I have slide
number one the slide number one does
anybody know what that picture is
I took it from that high school wall in
New York City
whether on it
Greenland is bigger than South America
North America we're very big we're
bigger than Africa the United States is
enormous much bigger than Europe and
everything else it was very flattering
but this right this pound of Russia over
here seems to be 25,000 miles not filed
Russian only mile apart so there's no
Antarctica that we could show this to
kids at school that companies keep
selling such junker says that seem to be
incredible to me I said years ago I want
to really think about total inventory of
our resources I needed background
against this a there's no visible
distortion I'd like to be able to take
the data with fear and project it out on
the fly now this is cover any way of
doing it like tell you rather quickly
how how it is couldn't completely unlike
any of the methods of projection have
been used as we find mathematically you
can divide it you can get three
triangles around a corner as in this
faculty hidden you can get further equal
out triangles around an octahedrons
corner and get five icosahedron around a
corner you can't get six cuz you have
you have 60 60 any of 360 degrees be a
plane going to invade this so in order
to come back in the south the limit
number of Eagle out flags around a
corner can only be five I took this
Faragher icosahedron with this 20
equilateral triangles each of the
corners at 72 degrees and I made a found
a method then I'll take a steel if you
think about a steel band three steel
bands because they have inch marks on
them if I bend one of them the
instruments remain still an inch of
power if I then have take three such
bands and I I'm going to put or I going
to take each one of the bands welds and
he's going to be traveling it along the
band and I've got a traveling strong rod
going through each one inch point
perpendicularly through it welding
the place very stiff carbon rod and so
it's six inches below six inches about
if I take those ends little rods would
pull them together with one steel band
the whole band will just bend but the
one inch points on this band don't
change a whole uniform scale whether
they're flat out are only in the band
condition I take three such rather say
three says steel rulers with three sets
out of the sets of rods going through
the right spoke about it and have a
little a I put a little bolted the ends
voting threes making a triangle looks
like a triangular fence
now I'm going to take all the bottom of
all those rods and pull them together
makes each of the the bands band but it
makes to the man bands been away from
the third band it opens up the the angle
of the corner makes what it calls
striker triangle so again up to 72
degrees that's me thence tackle so in
the icosahedron I have 20 special
triangles issues corners the 72 degrees
when I take them off holding my uniform
boundary scale so don't let any infinity
in the system at all then the corner
angles go from 70 to 60 that which we
call proud agreed spherical excess but
because it's done absolutely
symmetrically an equal angled triangles
then the there's a shrinkage of the data
inside the triangle but not along the
edge edge old absolutely true there's a
very mild shrinkage internally and the
most the most of the center and there's
three key to so minor there's no visual
distortion between the relative shape
and size of any of the paths on the
sphere or out on the flat now I'm going
to show you a map which will not look
familiar to you at all
next picture please this is made out of
my my triangles the child such that
wonderful somebody help me a little more
cried I think that as there is a light
pointer is it not the more cancer
good I think I can get up here question
well
there are on this map incidentally 100
white dots each one is one percent of
humanity located very accurately for the
center of that many people on this for
instance let's look at happen here is
then Greenland as Greenland and there's
you see then once so the size was traded
and now we have an Antarctic showing now
I gave you them the dots of the human
beings 1% each and here's the equator
going through South America only three
dots south of it this way
crater goes through Africa you have only
two dots south of it have knowing where
it goes through Java and Sumatra some
totally ten white dots as south of the
Equator but very close to the equator
ninety percent humanity there was north
of the crater and the small 10% that's a
little blow it thank you so very much
now here there's where the crater goes
through Africa is very creative going
through here and so Java and Sumatra
here so mainly then we have it where the
people living the southern air and
humanity knows very very little of this
great southern hemisphere where we just
came through the Antarctic and when I
was 16 years of age we have them I spoke
to you about the British this is it this
is the water ocean world and this is the
way things were when I was young and it
took notice people who one another took
them six months to reach each other my
father was in the Erie on Boston in the
leather importing was it great shoe
business here imported from Venice areas
in Calcutta
it took him exactly two months to go to
South America each way to Memphis each
way and took him exactly three months to
get to Calcutta and three months each
way so
humanity was really divided this is what
Kipling called the East
this is he called the West and said East
is East and West and West never the
trains for me because he does not in an
airplane world is thing you know
Waterworld
and here we have then that 54% humanity
29% and now the Americas only 12%
altogether
now in that water world you could not
ship change your cargos at sea the two
shifts to each other up so harbors are
the greatest importance as for that
great international trade and that's
coming to America's would have Boston we
had st. Louis which frees up in the
window
Boston however many times we got him
pretty badly iced up there's nothing to
compare with New York Harbor but deep
water and an enormous amount of a deep
waterfront well protected inside of of
the Long Island and Staten Island then
we have them on the west coast at San
Francisco Seattle their relatives review
few Harbor good harbors in the world in
North America then we hadn't built a
railroad between the east and west of
the San Francisco in the and The New
Yorker so forth now Houston 1961 three
jet airplanes which nobody knew were
going to be coming three jet transport
airplanes outperform the Queen Mary
Queen Elizabeth the steamship United
States in the Year 1961 ships of the sea
became obsolete again big big
evolutionary event but Wow humanity gets
from here to there from Iran they're
getting there by air which utterly
undreamed on my way my mother's time so
we have them here is a great water ocean
world and the British were running it
then found we've got down to the
Southern Pacific here you get on the
roaring fall to thee by the world what
goes around west to east the water went
faster than the crystalline earth and
the winds even faster still to have to
call the Roaring Forties going around
here you can't there's no such thing in
the and the Arctic but in the Antarctic
that it is and you see where the great
ice flows chewed through what we call
the great horn so the British discovered
all the ideas come south in the Pacific
got a roaring for all you got right in
Atlantic came South Atlantic it right on
the roaring floors in the Indian Ocean
Indian Ocean right in the Pacific again
they then went through the British god
they got it southern tip of South
America from South Africa Australian New
Zealand they got in America around the
people are all way out here no idea what
so this is a picture you're seeing first
time the British Empire which
we're not eager for anybody to see
anyway there it is and now 1961 those
airplanes they drive sad next picture
please I'm number two so suddenly we
have here what are called a sky ocean
world it's the first time in your life
or any if you haven't seen this map
before it's the first time humanity is
able to see all the surface about her
without an invisible distortion of the
relative shape of size event in the past
and without any break in the continental
contours we have one world island and
one world ocean took me two years to
find out how to get all those sinuses in
the water but anyway there it is so
suddenly this is the new intimacy that's
right this way we're going to be gone
and we're still here I'm just reading
today this day's paper about and you're
getting in a new Convention Center for
350 million there ends there's so much
property in New York and San Francisco
that they do anything that convinces
them out to keep it going but absolutely
dead ugly ugly ugly we have then when I
was young 90% of Americans were unfarmed
today only 7% and all the people thought
for a moment hanging fire using those
cities or dormitories there's our big
University areas but they're obsolete as
anything and anything to do and the way
they were conceived originally and now
on this map you'll find humanity I now
find it it is 95 percent Amanda can
reach each other and the shortest great
circle air routes without going the
Atlantic Pacific or Indian Ocean so this
is a north-south world and I found
something else very fascinating is
coming in with E you may remember that
the delivery of electricity delivery of
anything from here to there there's no
way we get so much so fast as by Riya
and a limit of the practical
deliverability
from the world war 1 on up to recently
was only 350 miles when go across the
time zones but since the space program
came in got anybody called ultra-high
voltage without apparently now deliver
1,500 miles
I made a world Network I like to go
energy networks not only then showing
how we then go across our time zones and
integrate those time zones will increase
really nicely from here to Alaska and in
Alaska we can reach right across the
restaurant have been there building
hydraulic electric stations of all in
northerly flowing rivers in here fifteen
hundred miles you can reach across to
the Russian Network where that means
they can get into the China network and
all the rest of the world
now when Trudeau was about to make his
first trip to Russia
I hear friends and I showed him my
electrical energy network grid and he
was very excited by so he took it he
gave it a breast lift breast implant is
his technical people shack in they said
come look the very brave very practical
to them I can simply say to you and all
the nonsense going on in our world money
well today we completely separated money
from wealth wealth being the ability to
take care of human life we have as I
just gave you a little while ago we
build it takes you everybody halves and
the others we have frog Bill and
billionaires on the planet right now by
the way the game a money is being played
keep everything very scarce again so
that the money game is current will go
out completely we're going to be mess
but what will happen to we'll all get
onto the but it was the accounting
system of the universe its energy energy
in time energy in time and nothing else
so we're going to get on energy time so
the minute we get on the same grid it's
going to be very great easy to really
have the the the crate of the
fractionating whatever we need to do way
of accounting can be done this way
absolutely beautifully so I'm going to
give you a few little quick in size now
that that is all I'm going to show you
the way it fixed all I want there was we
have the lights on I mainly just want to
give you a sense of very Swift oh no
whoa one more one more one more one more
right sharpen it up best you can
now people you won't be able to read
this chart so I just simply tell you
what it's all about
it is a chart that is 800 years long
my new way too much here this child I
wanted to have if I could a way of
charting gains of science against time
within science of course we have then
you say pure science that within pure
science you have the isolating of the
chemical elements and the isolating the
chemical almost happens to be a closed
system affair where membership is
absolute and wild by the number and
after all the numbers have to be filled
we have one electron one proton etc etc
nobody can cheat in any way
we have when history opens man humanity
had already discovered and was using the
we have carbon lad ten mercury silver
copper sulphur gold and iron on this
chart I go up one step every time we say
the chemical element so it starts 9
steps I is 800 1200 ad is the first
known isolation of a chemical a mother
by human being isolate that's where my
chart starts we go 200 years then it
comes to ad and a moment 200 years more
than phosphorus then 75 years in sunny
starts climbing very rapidly you see an
accelerating time and a slow down time
accelerating slow down the accelerations
are always peacetime these slowdowns are
always well time now get to a point
where and now get the pointer again and
suddenly this very much was flattening
out here this is that this is 1932 s a
depth of the depression but also the in
which we've made the 91st isolation
chemcam is only 90 out of 90 to 91 only
president on a planet circuit isolate
and rate we have here them shelves are
fall for the first time in history we've
taken the physical universe apart in its
own unique chemicals to be reassociation
into preferable ways from there are
negating the post uranium and then
suddenly going like this now very
interesting they come in here they don't
come in by the number of chemical number
37 might be the 17th isolation and so
forth but from here on they coming in
exactly by the numbers it's a very
extraordinary thing and right against
this background of pure science we have
then applied science obviously and what
does humanity try to do with this tomp
capability it tries to close it starts
naked and the afternoon to get some
skins on its own get Muslim they still
get in the cold then put a double skin
in that attempt and get ready to look
older still I find them against this
baked background of cider I said I give
you man as a then the requirements of
developing an environment control device
which he can get into and from inside of
it
control the energies operating outside
to take him in one complete circuit of
our planet about they're going to have
absolute standard performance
requirement against this background so
here is goes around in a wooden sailing
ship for the first time three hundred
fifty years later goes around and a
steel steamship 75 years later goes
around in an aluminum airplane
35 years later goes around an exotic
metals rocket at the time of this wooden
sailing ship nobody could dream of the
possibility of a steel steamship the
time that steel steamship nobody could
dream of aluminium airplane let alone we
hadn't learnt a flyer
times and romanum airplane nobody could
dream of exotic metals rocket so yes
having something enormous acceleration
going on here yeah this basic
acceleration of science against time we
have a contraction of 350 years
seventy-five years 75 years this one
took two years to go round this one took
two months to go around
this took two weeks ago around this one
took a little over an hour you're
witnessing visibly three third power
acceleration it's implicit on this shot
to go to 1985 right in here I'm gonna
have to send you around in a way
inconceivable at the time we've done it
gonna have to send you around by radio
this shot is the most powerful thing
I've ever had to get me to really feel
want you to feel the acceleration that
we're in because all the things that
you've been very familiar with like the
nations are going to go and you see in
that case the United States going into
bankruptcy going into all the great
power really going from it very rapidly
you don't have all kinds of things
coming apart that you've been for
they're familiar with and in this place
you're going to be coming some of the
things have been talking to you about
I've taken a lot of your time and let me
see what but we are going away with
chronic about time that is the end of
slides you can put on the lights again
now it is now 9:30
I've been exactly and I the hour and a
half that we're supposed to now we're
supposed to get into questions you have
a choice of asking me questions or
letting me ask myself the question been
asking myself a very long time and
answering them some kind of order for
you
I have a telephone and I keep getting
telephone calls at 3:00 and 4:00 o'clock
in the morning
and people say I'm calling in long
distances that seem to justify the
strange hour and I say do I know you're
gonna say no I said I've got a very
important question to ask you
I said all right I assume then you must
think I have an answer that's why you're
calling
I do have an answer because fifty-two
years ago I made up in mind I don't ask
anybody else in question I'm going to
find out for ourselves so you won't
really want me to help you I suggest you
hang up so I listen I listen have got
the sake few of them do hang up but they
start their talking and then I know they
just will only call up to show off I
hang up anyway I would like to give you
a little bit about I think of some of
these things that you're going to not
only have see all the great great
nations going and going they'll have to
go within ten years I feel that too
to have a very I've got to try through a
little more on the function of humans in
the universe which I spoke about is
having a mind capability I said what can
I find this common to all lives in all
history right up to his minutes second
that is common to all lives there
problems problems problems they're
always hereafter problem solving and for
any good at problem solving you get much
more difficult problem solver you don't
come to utopia at all it was exactly the
opposite direction the trick right here
for problem solving and we've been human
access to some of the great design of
universe to help us solve the problems
and say let's you and I look at a great
design like Boeing 747 drop try they're
all these instruments all those
instruments are connected we're
different possibly a ship of the power
plant in there and there's an airframe
every bit of critical information
regarding that ship is coming to you and
this is Natalie just to people who don't
get in the technology to think about
what's really going on here
in design designing a single family
residence 500 drawings is the most you
have to have I mean there's a thousand
of this type of nail the 500 do and the
tolerance 16 inch is fine again into the
automobile which they're moving around
with different parts of different rates
but you have to really look after that
we get to 5000 types of passed an
automobile and tolerances of ten
thousands of an inch we're getting that
Boeing 747 we're up to about 50 thousand
types of paths with Thomas assembly as
the minister in addition there's more
engineering goes in one rivet than the
Boeing 747 there's a hold of a single
family drama or even to an automobile
friend and they're that beautiful things
in the sky we have then baby it has it
has to be able to take 650 miles an hour
which is ten times the velocity of a
hurricane and the resistance increases
the second power of the other speed so
that the ferocity
interaction in the Boeing 747 with the
with the atmosphere is a hundred times
the frost layer again you know way for
imagination with you and that's that
thing going wrong the silver thing going
like that there's a minute you take take
350 tons and and landed 100 at 150 miles
an hour
music going white piece of design
when they when they say better fasten
your seatbelts old mummy today the
stress involved with that ship is
criminal taking Queen Mary over Niagara
Falls saying to a bumpy today this
incredible piece of design and Humana
know so little of this the ignorance of
humanity because of the what I've said
of a invisibility of the reality that
today there are 40 million engineers and
scientists on our planet but that's only
1% humanity and the 99% don't understand
science because they don't understand
the language of science and the 99%
don't understand the language of science
and words being quite new to them think
of the word technology is something new
they don't know that all the science has
ever found is the unit of the most
incredible technology so the 99% think
of technology is something new it's
weaponry and machinery to compete for
their jobs and they think they're
against it so here we have humanity is
only out to really make it is by a
design revolution our using technology
to really make humanity success to be
proud of the great successful universe
itself so we have that's that's a really
very tough one that relates primarily to
the the fact that the mathematics is the
wrong is is in the blockage was injected
and adjustable to them until the minute
I'd like to get that point out of the
way in a hurry I became convinced when I
was very young the nature was
co-ordinating anyway not best expressed
by the mathematics I was being taught
I've been taught for instance about AI
that you couldn't design a circle or
sphere without using time and I was
taught as I stayed in mathematics the
pie was but it called transcendental
irrational could never be resolved so I
said every time nature makes a bubble
how many sick times you gotta have pie
before she discovers the can be resolved
but times nature decided to make a
fake bubble I don't nature's using pine
as something Nature has departments of
physics and mathematics and biology and
has that Department had meetings to know
what they're doing
leaf falls in the water I think she has
only one Department I'm eager to find if
I can and I found nature never saying
what shall I do
I don't have to make Mason knew what
this was I don't know what it was making
exactly them so I said I'd like to find
nature coordinate system and I don't
think it's gonna be XYZ flat
perpendicular world because that was
when we thought of the Flat Earth so
that been very convenient it was true
and I said I I made myself a tubular
necklace of fog tubes and I found didn't
hold of shapes right I don't think she's
using a square either cuz it there's no
such thing - it won't hold the same I
think next year I want to get anywhere
near what she's doing I'm going to have
to deal in her in the terms of right for
the beginning with all the energy
qualities I have to have heat has to
have has to have longevity has to have
weight and I saw the centimeter gram
second system tried very hard to get it
but it never could get the temperature
in so I said I'm going to deal in
vectors
I like vectors and I learn about those
in the neighborhood Kadim II I've been
taught about a straight line by my
teacher at school she said straight this
is a straight line that said didn't look
right straight to me and she said wasn't
and she said it went to infinity and I
said where's the other end goal and
so I didn't like the kind of things
being taught at school at all and and I
finally then got into pursuing nature's
own coordinates and I'm pointed out to
you that nature there's not a operate
perpendicular parallel they say is
convergent and divergent she's
radiational divergent gravitation
convergent everything that experiences
to do with waves going under x-ray so I
discovered nature's own coordinate
system turns out of a nominally
triangulating world where the minimum is
the smallest system in university
tetrahedra in the minimum are only
polygons self-stabilizing is a triangle
and that is the tetrahedron is the
smallest simplest structural system in
the universe over we got into this you
read my book synergetics for any rate
and another book volume 2 will be coming
out in September this year and it's very
very much more voluminous and and with
ever absolutely confident now we really
have found nature's coordinate system
entirely rational - charlie conceptual
and any little child can really
understand it and enough about that but
I think it's going to be possible then
through the video try the nitrate 99%
humanity don't understand science the
technology can become extremely
appreciative of it really almost
overnight and that would make it
possible then to get them oriented
charge exercising the option to make it
with a design revolution now coming back
to humans and universe and their
functioning and then the fact that they
have access the great design of universe
and there are some of it and they have
then also problems problems problems
coming back to that great big Boeing 747
superbly design all those instruments up
there giving all the critical conditions
on board of the ship both the power plan
and the airframe I'd say then next to
each one of those this was able to be
another dial which would be bringing an
automated response to the typical set of
conditions of obtaining and as those
didn't work then the pilot himself
engineers can take over on the controls
then right I say in order to have a an
eternally regenerative universe
which is what we call scenario universe
and now they're not an instant universe
and that they do not have a tender
regenerative universe which is
understand efficient you'd have to have
then some local information gathering
and some local problem solving in the
terms of the fundamental design of that
universe itself
I said humans have been given that
capability quite clearly we've been able
to go out together
and information living have been in
lightyears around us that we are here
for local information gathering local
problem solving in respect to the
maintaining the integrity of an
eternally regenitive interest now make
sure the enemy has an important function
to fulfill does not say all the eggs in
one basket she fishes yes in order to
have humans humans on the universe to do
this don't have to use an enormous
amount of energy we can't get enough
through our skins from the Sun that
carry on so we have all the vegetation
impounding the Sun radiation for us and
then we have that vegetation then having
to be rooted so that you can get water
it can withstand the enormous winds and
and also take care of its hydraulic
compression requirements and get water
back in the sky because the vegetation
rooted it can't go out and planted seeds
in preferred places so in nature then
and these it's very much cheaper than
human beings doing on a planet and she
then have each tree lunching and little
flying machines that little seeds of
either many many thousands fewer than
may mainland where they will be
prospering
many of them were not so when she has a
very important function and very poor
chance of survival of the actually being
realized
she makes many SAS I say she would not
have that the function we have to
perform would not be just and this one
little team on board a little planet
Earth the same function would be planted
many place in universe and this
particular one I say we've now come
through the the being do not design
deliberately Nathan helpless ignorant
gotten the point where really discover
these beautiful principles that we our
minds are everything their muscles
nothing I say we're in final examination
now as to whether we're really going to
qualify and know if we'd really qualify
I must take a win we must get out of the
way forever I did after earning a living
then really get go on without real
function of solving local problems of
universe anymore more information so I
think I'll examination for my
acceleration curves say we only have
about 10 years to make it fact I'm down
to about 8 years now so maybe Charlotte
still would know but if the acceleration
is enormous that's the main thing and so
then you say what can I do about it
the way things are set up now all this
political system and I don't have
anything do the political decisions so
everything really depends on you
personally I wish I had a blackboard
here but I'm going to have to do
something with you mentally because we
all have very good imaginations I'm
going to give you a triangle now I'm
going to take bisect the edge of that
triangle in the Kinect I got the edge
edge reach to edge modulus 2 is 1 2 3 4
triangles gonna make triangle now edge
module is going to be 3 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9
thank you edge modulus 4 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 so 16 is 2 to the
to the second power and 9 is 3 to the
second power so forth you can say
triangle instead of squaring and you
find that only triangles only polygon
holds the shape and everything
discovered square is 2 triangles nature
is always most economical when nature
multiplies itself times itself where she
does time and again which is nature
doing triangle rings of squaring I just
gave you experimental evidence squares
don't even hold a shape which is nature
using you good anybody goes out of this
room saying squaring with humanities all
through
his question from now on about your
personal integrity in daring to really
go long experimental evidence they
really speak about it do something about
it we do the whole thing kind of work
because we do have all the evidences
that we now have the capability to make
it so it's going to really depend on
your personal integrity I can give you
the same thing showing there I'll make
it a little cube out of necklace of
tubes just falls down trout that
traveled I put travel together makes the
octahedron holds its shape all
triangular and right when we use the
cube for unity as we do send me in gram
second where Cuba water cetera cetera
cetera we find that it is the only
reason it holds its shape it does is
because you have six square faces don't
you under cure but I put a diagonal
across each face makes it there's six
edges of tetrahedron was at a treatment
holding it then it has them when you do
that it has four 1/8 octahedral
superimposed on the trial phases of the
tetrahedron when the tetrahedron is
unity the octane is volume before and
the cube is exactly volume of three I
could go on then to show you that we
then with tetrahedron octahedron filling
space they're doing written gamut all
this in the third power where you can
show you quite clearly the module is run
and come out with one set Regents the
modules two is eight saturated edge
module is remember Tempe do not fill all
space by himself that be complemented by
the updater a volume of four so I can
simply show you this leads to the edge
reads module reads three the the volume
is 27 as the edge module reads for the
volume is 64 tetrahedron in terms of
Terra so I can assay
tetrahedron instead of cubing and if I'm
using cubing I'm using I'm three times
most vunerable available and that's
exactly right
the mathematics of science is so
absolutely ridiculous
had to get an imaginary number
everything to accommodate going out of
this universe if you say usually tetra
you stay right in the universe is all
conceptual
right from beginning to end don't have
to have any nonsense about there are no
models say when trenders nature suddenly
check in with mother so we say is the
models all the way and all of it is
completely in the transform booklet
anyway
go and just synergetics they do it so I
say again if anybody goes out of this
room saying tubing when you see said
power again we are through because you
need three times much universes
available very simple now so you I want
to really get out what I feel is what
you personally can do it's going to be
really depending on your are you willing
to really have everybody accommodated
are you really there everybody really
get there or you got started a girl
doesn't want that to happen etc etc are
you really going to go along with the
experimental evidence but whether we
make it or not then it's not a matter
how our leaders behave without the
humanity of self behaves it's not a
matter of a few big surviving it's a
matter of humanity and humanity going
virtual fact you were all now go to
vocabulary all got a enormous amount of
information and just how much guts have
we really got to go along with
information the information is that all
the all the old systems that are
obsolete they're not because they
weren't good yesterday at all they were
absolutely essential to I think the
umbilical cord wasn't a sensor of the
time we came out of the room but we're
coming out doesn't I said I'm not saying
that flag wasn't great yet say a replica
man has gone through incredible courage
and love and dedication you man to get
rid of this no no no faults at all with
yesterday but we're out of that room
we're supposed to be coming out now and
that's the vs. most dangerous time wrong
we're in birthday so I am very deeply
assuming I hadn't said anything about
tonight at all 19:27 was made of a man a
big myself experimental experimental
well seen little individual could really
do and do everything with artifacts not
trying to reform human beings but by
participating in the environment itself
because I saw you know 60 percent water
we're hydraulically designed hydraulic
compression etc that water freezes boil
in very small limits which have to be in
the biosphere and and and and any other
information gaining phenomena operating
on Mars and not look the way we do on
this particular planet there in
biosphere so I came to thinking about
many many things certainly about life in
an integrity and and mind and I came to
the working conclusion I was that's all
overwhelmed by the a priori intellectual
integrity by universal that there were
those generalized principle to be
discovered and that they really were a
great design and they were gonna be on
it could be intellectually expresses it
mathematically so I said I'm all found
with a great integrity and I'm assuming
them that I been born at a moment when
somebody exposed together
poking there next to the information is
here and I became really very much an
outsider because I just want to
understand I did not make go to the game
and making money and so well I've lost
on my friends my now not only unknown
generally but pretty much in this grace
for the few didn't know me and I said
I'm really Matt's pretty much of a
throwaway and I'd like to see what would
happen if you really made the assumption
about all the things as I meant giving
to that there it was implicit that we
could do some days so much to local
takes everybody
it was also seems to me that I saw that
human beings having this great hunger
and so forth gradually learning how to
then to domesticate a milk cow then
learn how to take the height of the cow
makes shoes and the shoe man making more
shoes they could wear and shoe man wants
to milk cows and milk can no cow man
runs a pair of shoes they realize they
can't cut the [ __ ] the cow up and still
it still milk it so you know then if the
man who drew the milk cow took him much
more time to grow mo the milk cows or
the man to make sure so this when they
invented money to make it make up for
that so I have I saw that nature in
order then to have human life going on
our planet but never needing great deal
of energy I spoke about having the head
of the vegetation to impound the Sun
radiation for us and this identity to be
completely at the interpret that is to
take the random receipts and could
written by
the beautifully molecular structures and
which other creatures could employ to
grow more and more orderly types of
species and so that we were this was a
very anti-entropic affair and rate with
the vegetation then during this
impounding and being routed it couldn't
reach the other vegetation to procreate
so make sure then invent it all in
mobile creatures whether worms are
butterflies to go back and forth the
traffic between all the vegetations to
cross pollinate them but they sure
didn't say the honeybee how much to go
out cross bond eyes all this vegetation
when they see them to give their me a
chromosome ik instructions to go after
honey this continually after honey and
inadvertently to knock off the pollen so
I saw nature was accomplishing all these
things that 90 degrees gave drive like
that so I saw then she had all these
human beings it honey money drive going
after money and they got a singer
anybody try to take my room singing so I
said what's what she really doing is it
90 degrees so I said supposing them I
make the working assumption the runner I
may as I'm giving them to that we have a
function if I committed myself to try to
abet that by developing environment
controls would help to make them able to
function and they're more effectively it
could be that if I was doing one nation
wanted she'd have I get on be very
mysterious for habit so I made with you
assumption at an enormous I said I have
to have absolute faith in the integrity
of universe and then if I'm doing what
nature wants I'll find myself getting on
site that is 52 years ago and I have
gone on all this time and I had to say
only the impossible has happened
continually day after day and I have
been able to get on I have been able to
get the artifact sound it requires
really actually many millions of dollars
actually but I never know and nothing to
budget it really only up the absolute
last second and then fade out I don't
get it wrong and I'm realizing wrong
track because there's nobody back my
paper but my own so I then Sam to try
this tacky well the fort attack and what
everybody else what next it needs to be
done
I made incredible number of mistakes but
have been able to get here but I think
with you around knowing that I am do
represent also experiment in seeing if
you can get out if you really try to do
what nature wants to get
rather than how do you look out yourself
now that that's a I mean I have I'm
overwhelmed by my face in this way I
tell you that like all of humans I
couldn't be we can and made many
mistakes the times when I lose my faith
and everything goes wrong and every time
it that's really dare to yield
absolutely then everything just works
out superbly now so I say I know we have
the option to make it I think that time
is very short I think if we're going to
make it's going to be better this your
youth and truth but really the most
extraordinary thing about that young
world is all worlds
that feeling you had a being loved and
this from if you only have a suddenly
loving so young world knows that stones
don't love stones so there's something
incredible in the world of loud so I
find that young world nobody's saying to
them get a real sensitivity anymore
they're really guarding their
sensitivity so they much more integrity
of daring to really go along with what
they see and then of what love tells
them so say if we do make it on a planet
and now we have the option it's going to
be by virtue of the fact that the youth
loves truth and the use of horse and all
hypocrisy so the going to be love of
truth of youth we may make it thank you
I've been read disappoint if you didn't
do that and I stood up hoping your word
I for the last five years I'm averaging
an audience of 1,500 every four days and
if you didn't stand up you'll be the
first audience that didn't know what I
feel it's very important for you is the
following I spoke about 90 degrees and
says like this
there's precession and when if you're in
the room and me like what I've said you
say I like what you said grease pretty
well in my experience seems very
reasonable but when you're doing what
you just did is I'm just saying I'm tone
I'm going to tell the people beside me
here that I like what it says so you
were talking to each other not to me and
very important because we are if we get
into very critical conditions ahead here
we are very liable to have I once you
remember about when Germany lost all
this money will go one they got a
dictatorship at which point the nobody
is allowed to know what an other one
thinks you're told what the thing and
we're and I will forget income and great
many emergencies the line will be a lot
of guns out there going to be a lot of
very sad things may happen unless you
all remember I'm able to tell you around
the world I've been making speaking
people people all response responding as
you did just and very important me be
able to tell you that this is apparently
even speaking pretty much the way
humanity around the world would feel is
reasonable to carry on thank you
you
[Applause]